et j'ai une très grande
sensibilité beaucoup de
bheur
passionné je m'appelle George dijou plus
connu dans le monde artistique sous le
nom de digema donc qui reprend
simplement les initiales de mon nom
prénom donc dijou george Marie di G ma
ça c'est pour me présenter j'ai 48 ans
ça fait
maintenant 25 ans que je suis artiste
sculpteur donc j'ai touché un petit peu
à tout le bois la pierre le basalt le
marbre et depuis 2 ans
maintenant les
métaux il est capable de travailler le
bois il est capable de travailler la
pierre il est capable de travailler le
métal on lui montre une fois une
technique de suite il se la pourpris on
a l'impression que c'est Tiné chez
lui j'insiste là-dessus c'est tellement
petit qu'on peut lui donner la forme
qu'on a envie donc rentrer dans les
creux passer sur les bosses former les
poes former la poitrine former le le le
le draperé par les écrou complètement de
volume et de taille différent me permet
de de créer tout ça
justement alors George il est artiste il
est né artiste c'est en lui c'est pas
quelque chose qu'il a mis en place sur
lequel il s'est formé c'est en lui c'est
c'est vital il faut qu'il crée parce
qu'il en a besoin c'est c'est un mode
d'expression donc on vit avec un artiste
on je vis avec lui et je vis avec ce
côté artiste qu'il est donc oui je
l'accepte intégralement dans tout ce
qu'il est et bien sûr ça ça donne ça
donne cette grande sensibilité ça donne
cette créativité à fleur de peau c'est
tout ça qui qui fait de lui l'artiste
qu'il est c'est pas une formation c'est
lui il est comme ça super génial quoi ça
ça fait partie aussi de mon
environnement quoi c'est l'air c'est la
Réunion c'est mon île c'est euh c'est
mon petit coin c'est euh mes baleines
c'est les Réunionnais enfin j'adore
quoi
j'adore